Whether it's music, sports, or film, if there's
something people love, you can count on fans
crossing the line into full blown crazy.
And comic book fans are no exception, especially
since Marvel movies began dominating at the
box office.
So grab your Mjolnir and hold on tight, because
here's a look at a few Marvel fans who took
things too far.
It ain't easy bein' green
In 2012, a 35-year-old Brazilian man named
Paulo Henrique dos Santos painted himself
green and dressed as the Hulk for a running
event.
Unfortunately, the paint turned out to be
super heavy duty stuff used on ballistic missiles
and nuclear submarines.
And whattya know?
It wouldn't wash off.
Even after 20 baths, Santos remained as green
as the Hulk.
It eventually took a crowd of friends 24 hours
of scrubbing to finally get the green paint
out of Santos' skin.
No wonder the Hulk is always angry!
(Roars)
"What the hell?"
The best there is at what he does
In October 2017, during an Australian comic
convention, a 28-year-old man dressed as Wolverine
was arrested for allegedly playing his part
a little too well.
Around 2 a.m., after being kicked out of a
pub on Sydney's King's St., the Wolverine
fan allegedly attacked two men, injuring one
and knocking the other unconscious.
Both victims were brought to the hospital
while the man dressed as Wolverine was arrested.
It was not revealed if the dispute began over
an underground cage match or if either of
the alleged victims had called the wanna-be
Wolverine a "dirty mutie" before hostilities
broke out.
Spider-Man: hero or menace?
What's better than one Spider-Man?
Well, the answer is lots of Spider-Men, right?
"Earlier today tragedy striking the musical,
Spider-Man Too: 2 Many Spider-Men.
The show, billed as the most Spider-Men ever
assembled on one stage."
Well, if J. Jonah Jameson were real, the crimes
allegedly perpetrated by people dressed as
Spider-Man would've made him feel pretty vindicated.
For instance, a robber dressed as Spider-Man
allegedly held up an HSBC Bank in the Bronx
in April of 2017 as part of a Spidey crime
spree involving a number of attempted thefts.
And that's not the first time.
From NYC, to Frederick, Maryland, to sunny
St. Cloud, Florida, Spider-Man seems to be
the hero costume of choice for would-be criminals.
But there are heroic Spider-Men as well, such
as the Birmingham, England Spidey who donned
the suit to feed the homeless.
And then there's Kevin Gordon-Prior, who reportedly
broke up a brawl between around 30 or 40 people
in England while dressed as Spidey.
And it wasn't the first time he made headlines
for saving the day as Spider-Man, either.
Hey, with no power comes great responsibility.
The King of Pop Art
At the 2009 San Diego Comic Con, shortly after
Michael Jackson's death, Stan Lee opened up
about the King of Pop's interest in Marvel
and Spider-Man.
Lee claimed he and Jackson had sat down once
to discuss the possibility of pooling their
resources to buy Marvel Comics, with at least
part of Jackson's incentive being to get control
over film portrayals of Spider-Man.
Lee said,
"I'm not sure whether he just wanted to produce
it or wanted to play the role.
Our conversation never got that far along."
Jackson playing Spidey may sound far-fetched,
but it apparently wasn't the only superhero
he had his eye on, as X-Men screenwriter David
Hayter revealed in 2017 that Michael Jackson
wanted the film role of X-Men founder Professor
X.
Seeing Red
When you think of the most extreme, hardcore
fans and the subjects of their obsession,
you probably wouldn't choose Captain America
bad guy The Red Skull as the most obvious
subject of such intense passion.
But Venezuela's Henry Rodriguez has taken
fan obsession to a whole new level, even undergoing
facial reconstruction to look more like the
arch villain.
His transformation includes facial and eye
tattoos, cutting off his nose, and subdermal
implants in his face and brow.
And did we mention he CUT OFF HIS NOSE?!
Unfortunately, all that face-altering has
him looking less like the Red Skull and more
like Wrex from Mass Effect.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!